let's get some practice naming ionic
compounds so i have a formula for an ion
for an ionic compound right over here
but how would i say this and if you get
inspired pause the video and try to work
it out on your own
well we could see that it has some
magnesium and it has some phosphorus and
the convention is is the positive ion is
written first so if this follows the
convention the magnesium is going to be
our cation
and when you look at magnesium in the
periodic table right over here it makes
sense that it is going to be
the cation because it is a group two
element an alkaline earth metal and when
those get ionized they tend to lose two
electrons they tend to have they have
two electrons in their outermost shell
and so when they ionize they tend to
lose those so magnesium when it ionizes
tends to be
let me
when magnesium ionizes it tends to be
magnesium
two plus
and so this is probably each of these
three magnesium ions are probably
magnesium two pluses so we could if we
want just to see what is going on in
this compound we could write it like
this which isn't what you would
typically see but this is just to see
what the constituent ions of this
compound actually are
now as i mentioned the cation tends to
be written first so that's the magnesium
and the anion tends to be written second
and that is the phosphorus here if we
follow the convention
so that's the phosphorus right over here
and does it make sense that phosphorus
would be an anion well phosphorus is out
on the right hand side of the periodic
table right over here in order for it to
complete its outermost shell it wants to
gain one two
three electrons so when it ionizes it
makes sense that it gains those three
electrons so that phosphorus becomes
phosphide three minus and so these two
phosphoruses in this formula we could
write like this so we have two phosphide
anions
so we could just write it like this now
the whole reason why i wrote out the
constituent ions like this is to make
sure that it'll all end up being neutral
the magnesiums the three magnesium ions
will have a collective six plus charge
and the two
phosphides are going to have a
collective six minus and so when you add
the six pluses and the 6 minus they are
all going to cancel out so let me write
this you have 6 plus
and then you have 6 minus which once
again makes us feel good that we're
understanding this ionic compound well
because an ionic compound they didn't
write any net charge here so this is
going to be neutral so the ion the the
cations and the anions are going to
cancel out
but once again what do we call this
thing
well the convention is is we just write
the elemental name where we say the
elemental name for the cation so this is
going to be magnesium
magnesium
and then we say we say the eyed version
of the anion so this is phosphorus we
say phosphide so this is going to be
magnesium
phosphide and actually i don't have to
capitalize it so let me write it all
lowercase
magnesium
magnesium phosphide
and you might be saying hey this doesn't
have a lot of information in it how do
you if someone just told me magnesium
phosphide how do i construct what i did
what we originally started with
well the answer is you would have to say
okay magnesium is our cation it's right
over here it's a group two it probably
it's going to have a positive two charge
when it ionizes so you would look at
that
and you'd say okay phosphide well that
tends to have a three minus charge when
it ionizes which we saw over here and
then you'd say okay well what ratio
would i have to have between these two
things in order for them to cancel out
well if for every three of these of the
magnesiums i have two phosphides well
then they're going to cancel out and so
that's how you could go from the name to
the actual formula which we will
actually do in the next video